le 27 juillet 2023 le sénateur américain
Ron Weiden écrit une lettre officielle
au procureur général du Département de
la Justice des États-Unis à la chef de
la commission fédérale du commerce au
directeur de l'achat de sécurité du
cyber et des infrastructures aux
inconnus sous le nom de 6A autrement dit
cette lettre interpelle les trois
personnes les plus puissantes du monde
dans la régulation des entreprises
privées américaines du numérique elle
ouvre avec la phrase suivante je cite en
traduisant je vous écris pour demander à
vos agences d'intervenir pour tenir
Microsoft responsable de ces pratiques
négligentes de cybersécurité qui ont
permis le succès d'une campagne
d'espionnage chinoise à l'encontre du
gouvernement des États-Unis
en l'occurrence widen fait référence à
des anomalies suspicieuses détectées en
juin 2023 par le sisa et par le Bureau
Fédéral d'investigation plus connu sous
le nom de FBI ce n'est qu'une fois ces
anomalies détectées que Microsoft a
lancé une investigation pour constater
une cyberattaque en cours et pour
reconnaître des failles critiques dans
le fonctionnement de ses services Cloud
notamment les services e-mail comme
Outlook et Microsoft Exchange le
nombreux comptes sensibles du
gouvernement américain utilisé pour
toutes sortes d'échanges classés
confidentielles avaient été hackées
probablement par un groupe chinois
appelé Storm 0.558 et alors comme on le
verra c'est très loin d'être la première
fois que des failles majeures sont
trouvées dans les systèmes critiques de
Microsoft pourtant déjà massivement
acheter et utiliser par de nombreux
organisations majeures comme non
seulement le gouvernement de la plus
grande puissance économique du monde
mais aussi très probablement
l'entreprise dans laquelle vous cher
spectateur travailler et d'autres
accusations de négligence irresponsable
ont fusée depuis sur lesquels je
reviendrai aussi facilement pire à table
qu'un PC Windows mais dans un contexte
de tension géopolitique grandissant dans
le monde avec des coups d’état en
Afrique la guerre en Ukraine les
provocations de la Chine et la
banalisation de la haine dans les
démocraties les plus solides du monde
dans un contexte où deux surcroît le
cybercrimes pullule et devient de plus
en plus rentable avec une croissance
exponentielle des coûts qui ont gendres
et une implication d'une diversité
grandissante d'acteurs malveillants et
surtout dans un contexte où toutes les
organisations du monde qu'il s'agisse de
gouvernement de banque de réseau
électrique ou d'hôpitaux toutes ces
antiquités deviennent de plus en plus
dépendantes du bon fonctionnement du
cloud c'est-à-dire de services
informatiques gérés à distance par des
entreprises comme Microsoft la
découverte de l'exploitation du cloud de
2 Microsoft par des hackers chinois a de
quoi préoccuper bien au-delà encore du
cas des emails du gouvernement américain
un vieux dicton dit que personne n'a
jamais été licencié pour avoir acheté du
Microsoft l'historique des failles
Microsoft devraient peut-être
questionner ce dicton aussi facilement
pire à table qu'un PC Windows sachant
tout ce qu'on sait de la négligence de
la cybersécurité par cette entreprise et
sachant à quel point la sécurité
économique des entreprises et donc la
stabilité financière des employés dépend
aujourd'hui de cette cybersécurité avoir
acheté du Microsoft aujourd'hui sans
avoir évaluer les risques devrait être
inadmissibles en fait aujourd'hui il y a
même une probabilité très loin d'être
négligeable que accepter une offre de
Microsoft pour votre entreprise c'est
permettre à des acteurs du cybercrime
comme des entreprises concurrentes ou
des gouvernements étrangers d'accéder
aux informations sensibles de votre
entreprise voire de prendre le contrôle
sur vos opérations dans le Cloud sachant
les failles connues de Microsoft cloud
il serait irresponsable de ne pas
questionner les habitudes numériques de
nos entreprises
avec ces fuites de données il ne change
rien à ses habitudes il a gardé par
exemple cet agenda Pillon aussi
facilement piratable qu'un PC Windows
historiquement l'un des premiers gros
électrochocs pour le gouvernement
américain fut l'attaque terroriste du 18
septembre 2001 et oui j'ai bien dit 18
septembre une semaine après celle que
vous connaissez à savoir l'attaque
physique sur les tours du World Trade
Center de New York un verre informatique
hybride a provoqué des catastrophes
inédites ce verre était appelé Nimda qui
est le verlan lettre à lettres de admin
l'exploitait des vulnérabilités dans les
systèmes Microsoft pour se répliquer et
se propager de machine en machine
causant toutes sortes de surcharge
informationnelles des systèmes
d'information qui ont empêchaient alors
les machines d'effectuer les tâches pour
lesquelles elles étaient programmées
mais même s'il y a de quoi reconnaître
que minima était en effet spectaculaire
et très coûteux il ne s'agissait en fait
pas de la plus grande crainte de la
Défense américaine qui craignait
beaucoup plus des attaques capables de
prendre le contrôle de système
d'information critique de manière
indétectable les ennemis sont bien plus
dangereux quand on ne les voit pas et
d'ailleurs pendant de longs mois
l'infiltration de Microsoft parlait à
coeur chinois était de ce genre
quoi qu'il en soit c'est dans un climat
poste 11 septembre de grandes
préoccupations pour les risques sur la
sécurité nationale que Microsoft fut mis
sous grosse pression par les autorités
américaines c'est ainsi que certainement
sous la pression des agences étatiques
Bill Gates le fondateur milliardaire de
Microsoft a écrit un mémo censé marquer
le jour où la cybersécurité était
devenue la plus grande priorité de
l'entreprise je cite dans 10 ans
l'informatique sera une part intégrale
et indispensable de presque tout ce que
nous faisons Microsoft et l'industrie
informatique ne seront à succès dans le
monde que si les directeurs
informatiques les consommateurs et tout
le monde voient que Microsoft a créé une
plateforme de confiance numérique
le
quel c'est la première partie de cette
citation est une prédiction très juste
la seconde est en fait très
questionnable notamment car les citoyens
et les gouvernements échouent
constamment apprêter suffisamment
d'attention à la notion de confiance
numérique tant que des scandales
monumentaux de négligence de ces bières
sécurité seront ignorées nous semblons
voués à faire confiance à des outils
numériques auxquels nous ne devrions pas
faire confiance comme des téléphones
ultra connectés avec des micros
constamment branchés des applications
contrôlées par des gouvernements
autoritaires déjà largement engagés dans
la cybergure comme TikTok ou des
machines aussi facilement pire à table
qu'un PC Windows des machines dans
lesquelles nous enregistrons tant de
données sensibles et avec lesquelles
nous accédons à des systèmes que nous
voudrions être les seuls à pouvoir
contrôler comme par exemple nos comptes
bancaires j'ai un peu envie de dire que
si vous voulez vraiment optimiser sa
philanthropie Bill Gates devrait sans
doute s'intéresser beaucoup plus à la
cybersécurité notamment celle dont
l'entreprise qui l'a fondé et coupable
d’inattention avec pour conséquence la
mise en danger de milliards
d'utilisateurs de millions d'entreprises
et de milliers d'organisations
gouvernementales et internationales à
travers le monde alors pour être juste
avec Microsoft on peut largement
reconnaître que depuis 2001 ils se sont
beaucoup améliorés en introduisant
notamment le patch To's day en octobre
2003 les seconds mardi de chaque mois
des mises à jour critiques de sécurité
étaient proposées et devaient être
effectués par les clients pour protéger
leur système ce qui est d'ailleurs
conduit à ce qu'on appelle les
exploitations du mercredi qui tentent de
hacker les systèmes Microsoft qui pas
encore été mise à jour et d'ailleurs ça
ça me permet au passage de vous rappeler
de mettre à jour vos logiciels dès
qu'une mise à jour est disponible
surtout pour les logiciels qui
communiquent beaucoup avec internet en
particulier les navigateurs Web faire
Fox chrome ou Edge ceci étant dit
maintenant que l'informatique avance
très vite la mise à jour mensuelle
semble inappropriée selon beaucoup
d'experts notamment les développeurs des
systèmes open source comme Linux qui
préfèrent proposer une mise à jour dès
que celle-ci est disponible au lieu de
laisser un délai pendant lequel la
faille connue des développeurs peut
fuité et être connu des cyberataquants
quoi qu'il en soit malgré le mémo de
Bill Gates et malgré une amélioration de
l'attention donnée à la sécurité par
Microsoft des failles critiques des
systèmes de Microsoft n'ont cessé d'être
découverte et surtout d'être exploité
par le cybercrime parmi les cas les plus
spectaculaires on peut citer celui de
stocksnet en 2010 un verre informatique
de la NSA qui a exploité des failles de
Microsoft pour saboter le programme
nucléaire iranien en provoquant une
autodestruction difficilement
souhaitable des machines à enrichir
l’uranium autre cas très grave en 2009
l'opération Aurora a permis à des
hackers chinois d'infiltrer de manière
durable des systèmes de nombreux géants
américains y compris Google en
exploitant une faille de Microsoft
Internet Explorer une faille que
Microsoft connaissait trois mois avant
la taille mais n'avait pas pris le temps
de corriger
puis en 2017 il y a eu Wana Cry un verre
informatique attribué à la Corée du Nord
qui exploite des failles de vieux
système Microsoft chiffres les données
de la machine cible et exigent une
rançon en Bitcoin pour déchiffrer ses
données on parle de ransomware et un
jeune mi-code avait d'ailleurs fait une
vidéo à l'époque de l'attaque et puis
plus récemment en 2020 des hackers
russes ont hacké solarwinz en exploitant
notamment des failles de Microsoft pour
pénétrer plusieurs parties du
gouvernement des États-Unis et faire
fuer des données sensibles
oh la table qu'un PC Windows et
justement dans sa lettre le sénateur Ron
Weiden rappelle que Microsoft
connaissait les vulnérabilités de son
système d'authentification depuis 2017
trois ans avant que la taille des
hackers russes est eu lieu et soit
détecté par les agences américaines mais
encore une fois Microsoft n'a pas réparé
la faille et n'a pas averti ses clients
qui utilisaient pourtant ces
technologies défectueuses comme l'écrit
widen Microsoft n'a jamais reconnu sa
responsabilité dans le hack de Solar
winds au lieu de cela microsoft a
utilisé cet incident comme une
opportunité de promouvoir son produit
azur ado les clients de Microsoft ont
entendu le message qui prétendait qu'il
était trop difficile de sécuriser les
clés de leur propre serveurs et qu'il
était plus sûr de laisser Microsoft le
faire pour eux trois ans plus tard les
revenus des services de sécurité cloud
professionnels de Microsoft ou atteint
plus de 20 milliards de dollars par an
voilà qui rend les failles critiques du
service mail de Microsoft d'autant plus
inexcusable surtout quand on sait que
leur communication récente tournait
surtout autour de chaque GPT une
solution elle-même rapidement hackée pas
si facilement pire à table qu'un PC
Windows et pourtant on est encore très
loin d'avoir égratigné la surface
émergée de l'immense iceberg des
problèmes majeurs de cybersécurité
présent dans les produits Microsoft je
vais me contenter d'inciter seulement
deux autres particulièrement révélateurs
le 4 juin 2021 pour le 32e anniversaire
du massacre de Tiana Men et alors que
des militants pro-démocrates étaient
réprimés à Hong Kong les recherches pour
thank man sur Microsoft Bing censurer
l'image et la vidéo de l'homme courageux
qui s'opposait au défilé de chars de
l'armée chinoise et qui était devenu le
symbole de moi de manifestation
pacifiste et pro-démocratique que les
autorités chinoises ont puni dans un
horrible pain de sang et même si plutôt
qu'un hack on peut y voir une complicité
de Microsoft avec une dictature
sanguinaire notamment rapporté et mise
en évidence dans le cas de l'utilisation
de Microsoft Bing dans la langue
chinoise Microsoft a préféré parler
officiellement d'erreurs humaines
erreur humaine ou non Microsoft a des
comptes à rendre au moins envers les
militants pro-démocratie à Hong Kong
enfin plus récemment en mars 2023 une
entreprise de cybersécurité tendbowl a
identifier une faille critique dans le
service cloud de Microsoft qui selon
leur PDG Amit yuan leur a permis
d'accéder au secret d'authentification
d'une banque ils ont alerté Microsoft
mais se plaignent de l'inattention de
l'entreprise à cette faille critique 120
jours après avoir rapporté le problème
la banque était ainsi toujours
vulnérable comme l'écrit Yorane c'est
grotesquement irresponsable voire d'une
négligence flagrante
thé Windows
cette idée donc Microsoft en a remis une
couche avec une faille qui affecte son
service cloud que Microsoft a prétendu
être particulièrement sécurisé pour
attirer de nombreux nouveaux clients
dépassés par les enjeux de cybersécurité
la confiance des clients a été de
nouveau trahie mais vu l'inattention
médiatique à cet événement majeur je
crains que les clients ne se rendent pas
suffisamment cons mais alors que
s'est-il passé pour comprendre
laissez-moi d'abord vous présenter le
système d'authentification que Microsoft
a mis en place pour ses services en
ligne et comment il est essentiel
garantir la sécurité des informations
des clients et de leurs accès aux
applications cloud de Microsoft enfin on
va surtout voir les grandes lignes avec
quelques implications et histoire de ne
pas vous perdre en gros pour utiliser
les services cloud de Microsoft vous
allez devoir d'abord suivre une
procédure d'authentification pour cela
vous devez envoyer des informations
d'authentification un serveur de
Microsoft typiquement une multiple
authentification avec mot de passe avec
confirmation via téléphone si tout va
bien le serveur d'authentification de
Microsoft va vous envoyer un jeton
d'authentification que le serveur à
signer en y incluant une signature
cryptographique produite à l'aide d'une
clé de signature autrement dit cette
signature est un certificat vérifiable
que seul une machine qui possède de la
clé de signature a pu produire retenez
bien que le jeton est certifié avec
cette clé censée être ultra secrète et
n'être enregistrée que sur des serveurs
de Microsoft auquel personne n'a accès
ça va être important pour comprendre le
hack du groupe chinois ensuite pour
utiliser un service cloud de Microsoft
comme Outlook Office cherpointdrive ou
teams votre machine va envoyer le jeton
signé à une application cloud de
Microsoft qui va vérifier la signature
du jeton si la signature est correcte
c'est à dire si elle correspond à une
clé de signature de Microsoft alors
l'application cloud va vous donner accès
à ses services notez que des
applications qui ne sont pas développées
par Microsoft sont aussi conçus avec
l'authentification via des jetons signés
typiquement celles qui ont une
fonctionnalité login via Microsoft en
fait l'intérêt du jeton signé c'est
justement que les applications Microsoft
ou non n'auront pas à développer leur
propre solution d’authentification elles
ont juste à vérifier que le jeton a été
signé par une clé de signature de
Microsoft mais du coup comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer la sécurité de la clé de
signature est absolument critique comme
on l'a vu les nombreuses applications de
Microsoft se contentent de vérifier la
validité de la signature d'un jeton
qu'on leur soumet pour donner l'accès à
leur service tels que spécifié par le
jeton et c'est pour ça que cette clé de
signature suit des procédures de
sécurité additionnelles dans le système
de Microsoft pour commencer cette clé
finit par expirer ce qui évite qu'une
clé volée puisqu'elle tire un accès
indéfini de plus elle est censée
n'exister que dans l'environnement de
production lequel est détaché du réseau
de machines des employés de Microsoft en
particulier même les employés de
Microsoft n'y ont pas accès on parle
parfois de sandboxing l'accès à la
production et restreinte et en
l'occurrence interdite aux employés mais
comme tout unboxing il demeure des
canaux de communication entre les
différentes sandbox en l'occurrence
entre le réseau de production et le
réseau des employés et il faut
surveiller ses communications comme le
lait sur le feu parmi les communications
possibles il y a en particulier le
transfert des informations de panne si
une machine du réseau de production a
une panne permet aux employés d'accéder
à des informations au sujet de cette
panne pour leur permettre de comprendre
et de réparer la panne en question ok on
a à peu près tout ce qu'il nous faut
pour comprendre la cyberattaque du cloud
de Microsoft ou du moins ce que
Microsoft a bien voulu révéler sous la
pression notamment du sénateur Ron
Weiden en avril 2021 il y a eu une panne
dans le réseau de production au moment
de la panne un enregistrement de l'état
du système au moment de la panne a été
effectuée Microsoft parle de crash jump
ce crash jump a été transféré au réseau
des employés sauf que comme vous vous y
attendez sans doute à cause apparemment
un bug se crash jump contenait une clé
de signature de Microsoft et
malheureusement les outils de détection
d'information sensibles dans le crash
jump de Microsoft ont échoué à détecter
la présence de cette clé ultra sensible
la clé a alors atterri dans le réseau
des employés qui est moins sécurisé ne
serait-ce parce que les employés de
Microsoft y ont accès et justement selon
Microsoft le compte d'un ingénieur de
Microsoft s'est fait hacker apparemment
par les attaquants chinois ce qui a
permis à ses attaquants d'accéder au
crash jump donc à la clé privée de
signature
aussi facilement pire à table qu'un PC
Windows qui leur a permis ensuite de
créer des jetons d'authentification et
surtout de les signer avec cette clé de
signature de Microsoft pour accéder à
des services cloud de Microsoft comme
les emails d'un client du service et
alors en principe ces attaquants on
n'auraient pas dû pouvoir aller bien
loin parce que la clé qu'ils ont volé
était censée expirer en avril 2021 et a
priori ils y ont à accédé après avril
2021 mais étrangement les applications
de Microsoft n'avaient pas encodé cette
expiration et ont permis aux attaquants
de continuer à exploiter la clé de
signature jusqu'en juillet 2023 au
moment où ils ont compris que cette clé
était en train d'être exploité un
mauvais escient et ce que l'on sait en
tout cas c'est que cette clé a été
utilisée pour en particulier accéder à
des emails un truc d'agence du
gouvernement américain
pas si facilement pire à table qu'un PC
Windows et alors permettre à une
puissance étrangère d'accéder aux
échanges confidentiels des autorités du
pays c'est déjà extrêmement grave mais
on peut douter que le hack s'est arrêté
là en effet les mêmes jetons signés
utilisés pour accéder à des emails
permettait à priori d'accéder aux
nombreux autres services de Microsoft
difficile toutefois d'en être sûr tout
dépend des détails et d'acceptation de
la signature des jetons par les
différents services en question en tout
cas il est improbable que ces attaquants
n'est pas essayé d'infiltrer davantage
de cible et en particulier d’établir une
présence persistante dans le service
cloud des nombreux clients de Microsoft
l'entreprise de cybersécurité Wizz
estime ainsi possible que les attaquants
ont modifié les mécanismes
d'authentification d'applications
via lesquels ils peuvent se connecter à
n'importe quel moment dans le futur pour
des informations plus précises au sujet
de l'attaque et pour mieux comprendre à
la fois ce que l'on sait mais aussi ceux
qui est encore très obscur qui soulève
en fait davantage d'inquiétude encore je
vous recommande de lire est excellent
biais de blog de l'entreprise Wiz à ce
sujet bref pour récapituler Microsoft a
fait fuiter une clé ultra-sensible dans
un crash jump puisa échoué à détecter la
présence de cette clé dans le crash jump
puis il y a eu le compte d'un ingénieur
employé piraté puis à valider des jetons
signés avec une clé de signature expirée
et encore là je n'ai listé que
quelques-unes des failles majeures dans
le système de Microsoft qui ont
eux-mêmes révélé voilà qui me semble
pleinement justifié le qualificatif de
pratique de cybersécurité négligeante
utilisée par le sénateur Wyden pour
décrire la confiance adéquate à avoir
dans les services informatiques fournis
par cette entreprise aussi facilement
piratable qu'un PC Windows
Microsoft semble très très loin des
standards de sécurité que son rôle
dominant dans le traitement de
l'information à l'échelle mondiale
devrait exiger et alors en 2001 c'était
déjà un gros problème mais en 2023 comme
le comprend très bien le sénateur Ron
wilden l'inattention de Microsoft à la
cybersécurité menace la sécurité
nationale car au-delà des nombreux cas
déjà très préoccupants dont on a parlé
aujourd'hui la cyberattaque de l'été
dernier expose surtout la banalisation
de l'omniprésence des failles dont les
services critiques de Microsoft sont
coupables d'avoir laissé traîner et le
danger civilisationnel de donner à
Microsoft le contrôle de serveur
responsable de choses aussi sensibles
que des transactions bancaires le
contrôle des réseaux électriques ou la
gestion des hôpitaux et des assurances
mais alors que faire la première chose à
faire c'est je pense de cesser de fermer
les yeux ou de détourner notre attention
de ces risques civilisationnels en
cédant par exemple à la tentation de
disqualifier d'alarmist ce qui étudie
ces problèmes prenez le temps de bien
évaluer l'état de la cybersécurité des
systèmes d'information critiques même
sans rentrer dans les détails techniques
il est largement possible d'évaluer
l'ampleur des risques simplement en
s'informant des dispositifs mis en place
pour les atténuer que ce soit par
Microsoft par votre employeur ou par nos
gouvernements et si vous voulez vraiment
savoir plus il y a à mes yeux une
référence incontestable à savoir le
livre extrêmement documenté this is how
vettermit the world Hans qui traduit en
français signifie c'est comme ça qui me
disent que le monde va terminer
un livre écrit par la journaliste Nicole
perroff New York Times spécialisé dans
les questions de cybersécurité depuis
plus d'une décennie ce livre a
bouleversé ma compréhension de la
fragilité de notre civilisation et il
n'y a nul doute à mes yeux que si vous
le lisez vous verrez aussi un monde très
différent un monde qui ressemble
vraiment à un château de cartes que de
nombreux groupes obscurs veulent
détruire au moins pouvoir détruire et
que les démocraties sont bien trop peu
inclines et promptes à consolider une
fois informé je suis sûr que vous
questionnerez en particulier
l'inattention des entreprises privées à
la cybersécurité et vous questionnerez
également leurs investissements massifs
dans le développement de nouvelles
technologies qui sont beaucoup moins
sécurisées encore en particulier plutôt
que d'acheter aveuglement des services
de Microsoft parce que c'est ce que tout
le monde fait et que personne n'a jamais
été licencié pour ça j'espère que vous
envisagerez des solutions alternatives
notamment celles qui ont un track record
de cybersécurité beaucoup moins
compromettant comme les administrations
françaises commencent d'ailleurs à le
faire ceci dit une solution plus
efficace pour drastiquement augmenter la
cybersécurité de votre entreprise et
plus généralement de notre civilisation
cela reste la sobriété numérique
en particulier moins vous aurez
d'applications sur vos ordinateurs vos
tablettes et vos téléphones moins il y
aura de vecteurs via lesquels les
cyberataquants peuvent compromettre vos
informations avez-vous vraiment besoin
d'installer sur votre téléphone
professionnel l'application qui stylise
vos portraits avec un algorithme
génératif en particulier la mesure la
plus simple que vous pouvez effectuer
pour augmenter drastiquement votre
cybersécurité c'est désinstaller tous
les plugins obscurs et non essentiels
que vous utilisez dans vos navigateurs
web et plus encore dans vos
environnements de développement comme
Microsoft vs code c'est plugins ont
littéralement accès à vos codes et
peuvent parfois modifier la compilation
de votre code et si vous pouvez faire
une tâche sans faire appel à chaque GPT
ou tout autre solution développée dans
la précipitation je ne peux que vous
encourager et encourager vos entreprises
à faire sans et à ainsi réduire ce qu'on
appelle la surface d'attaque mais
surtout je vous invite à exiger beaucoup
plus des fournisseurs de services
informatiques de vos entreprises non
seulement au moment d'échanger avec mais
aussi et surtout en appelant les
politiques à imposer des audits externes
obligatoires voire dans le cas des
technologies massivement utilisées et
très probablement illégales d'adopter
une présomption de non conformité le
développement aujourd'hui de ces
algorithmes est extrêmement rapide il
est précipité et ça c'est par opposition
à d'autres industries si vous prenez
n'importe quel autre industrie mature
aujourd'hui donc je pense par exemple à
l'aviation industrie pharmaceutique ou à
l'industrie agroalimentaire on a mis en
place plein de systèmes parce qu'on sait
que ces industries sont dangereuses si
elles sont pas elles sont pas bien
contrôlées elles sont pas bien encadrées
on a mis en place plein de systèmes et
en particulier on a mis en place ce que
j'ai appelé la présomption de
non-conformité dans beaucoup de cas
c'est à dire que par défaut un avion je
monte pas dedans si je sais pas qui l'a
fabriqué aujourd'hui la plupart des IA
on sait pas qui les a fabriqué et ou si
c'est fabriqué par une entreprise dans
lequel j'ai pas confiance j'ai pas envie
de monter dedans mais ce qui se passe
c'est que l'avion est même interdit de
vol on a décidé de mettre en place des
protocoles avec des organes d'inspection
très bien financés et très légalement
notamment pour pouvoir vérifier la
conformité de l'avion avec une la loi
avant de l'autoriser à prendre tout ce
qu'on fait pas avec lia avec exactement
ce qu'on ne fait pas aujourd'hui avec
l'intelligence artificielle enfin je
vous invite à faire de la cybersécurité
un sujet de discussion surtout au sein
de votre entreprise que se passerait-il
si votre entreprise était sous la taille
celle-ci pourrait-elle se faire
facilement pirater par le premier
cybercriminel est-ce qu'il suffit de
compromettre un employé pour tout
compromettre comment réduire le risque
qu'un de vos nombreux collègues soit
compromis quel serait l'impact d'un vol
des données de vos clients ou de vos
fournisseurs quid d’une paralysie de
longue durée de votre système
informatique combien saiez-vous prêt à
payer pour rétablir un bon
fonctionnement de votre système
informatique si celui-ci était paralysé
si les réponses à ces questions sont
floues à vos yeux c'est qu'il vous faut
sans doute urgemment y réfléchir je vous
encourage à organiser des réunions des
séminaires ou des formations autour du
sujet et si votre entreprise a les
moyens vous pouvez aussi engager les
services de mon entreprise Kelly CARPA
qui en plus de développer des solutions
de sécurité offre de la formation et du
conseil en cybersécurité aux entreprises
clientes ne serait-ce que pour mieux
estimer l'ampleur des risques auxquels
votre entreprise est exposée
et puis justement le rapport souligne
cette dichotomie entre eux et bien cette
sécurité maximale au sein même des
structures de yafghani Prigogine mais
aussi la négligence envers la sécurité
numérique des données puisqu'on a réussi
à obtenir un million de documents et le
plus inquiétant dans tout ça c'est que
même avec ses fuites de données il ne
change rien à ses habitudes il a gardé
par exemple cet agenda sillon aussi
facilement piratable qu'un PC Windows
du montage et justement on faisait le
montage il y a une autre actualité qui
est sortie à propos de Microsoft
toujours qui aurait liqué 38 téraoctets
donc révélé toujours par les entreprises
de cybersécurité Wiz et en fait au
moment où des ingénieurs voulaient
partager ou liquide de recherche on y a
des Microsoft voulait partager des
données d'entraînement d'algorithmes qui
sont fait une mauvaise manipulation avec
Azura D et ils ont partagé en fait
plein de données internes à Microsoft y
compris des secrets et des mots de passe
un genre de choses horribles vraiment tu
ne vas pas très très bien avec Microsoft
en ce moment